hello guys i'm ryan right i'm gerry uh
was a podcast today fun little podcast
sorry I'm moving the mic around a little
bit um I mean readjust right now real
fast okay cool podcast uncut that's what
we do here we make it very real like the
re e to the l i wanted to talk about the
film's i'm calling I want to call this
one best movies of 2015 cuz I honestly
like I made a top 10 video and I wanted
to kind of just experiment with editing
and I was like this might be fun so I
did it over one of Veronica songs and i
just edited like wood through through
and footage of the movies and stuff and
I was kind of hoping that I wouldn't put
it in and I was contemplating like not
putting it in a specific order because
it changes like even in life when it
comes to my top favorite movies of all
time it's sometimes it changed you know
look I mean the thing about movies and
Generals like the when you get distance
from them and you pick up life
experiences you know movies play
differently yeah you know like I kind of
enjoyed the Godfather when I was a kid
but when I got older I realized how good
the gun father is you know yeah like it
really depends it does depend I what you
said is a great point like it's and the
comments I think our them that are the
most ignorant that I hate from most even
in life i hate it when people do that
thing of what that's your opinion [ __ ]
your opinion here's why your opinion is
wrong what it's like come on man movies
are about something else entirely
they're supposed to be for it's like
there are people who are going to like
it and people who don't like it it's not
a back basting round so all the noise
going on it's not like a fact-based
thing it's subjective well yeah and I
mean the thing about is like you can
break down a movie on
technical scale and and reach some kind
of objective right opinion or an
objective you know truth or something
like that but like I don't know like
movies a lot of movies are meant to
invoke something I guess emotional you
know you're supposed to have an
experience why you're watching people
play out an experience yeah yeah exactly
so and I was kind of trying to do it off
the top of my head yeah you know I was
like okay what are the top 10 that
really stood out on the top of my head
well yeah I feel like the key to any top
10 movie list our best of the year liz
just to be upfront with how you consider
things so you're not necessarily saying
these are qualitatively you know
mathematically the best movies this year
it's it's your favorites it's the ones
that you thought were the most memorable
yeah exactly the ones I thought were the
most memorable I don't come i'm not
coming from like a technical basis I
don't oh my god hello no I mean Laurel
Canyon [ __ ] woman don't know how to
drive need help with directions it's
called GPS Veronica she's never gonna
listen to his podcast so yes this is the
only time I stand up to Veronica is Ben
think of it this way I haven't you know
she chose to call and communicate with
you instead of just touching another
computer or she could have yelped where
the [ __ ] subway was and is what can he
really changed this now she interrupted
our uncut podcast no way to get them no
way to cut this out yeah it's like
Mission Impossible rogue nation I put
down as my number one and I got a lot of
crap for that you know like a lot of
people are putting down like Star Wars
and stuff the crap that I'm getting
permission if there are problems with
Star Wars like it it's just not cool I
thought I turn this off guys it's just
not cool to be like hey this movie is
not good it's not even in the top 10 cuz
I'm like that's just your [ __ ]
opinion you can't force me to not like a
movie with no like logical backup as to
what it's a data film what
the thing about top tens is like there
are so many of them now that I feel like
especially if you have your own name
like you know if you put the real
rejects 10 best or whatever then you
kind of have to impose a uniformity but
if it's just Ryan writes favorite movies
of the year [ __ ] personality the [ __ ]
out of that list you know yeah like and
like my I wrote a list of top 10 horror
and sci-fi movies and like I recognize
that some of these movies are not
qualitatively like the best movies but
out of everything I saw this year they
gave me something that I particularly
liked yeah that i found particularly
valuable for me so like this is one
man's pics yeah rogue nation for me I
like there are other movies were
sometimes I go back and forth you know
in some ways ex machina is probably my
favorite movie of the year but when I
think a Mission Impossible rogue nation
at I remember the experience I was
having with the film yeah you know and
that's what I that's where I come from
when it comes to making these lists
isn't what was the experience I had
watching this not what are the technical
detail like people complain that I add
Jurassic world as even number 10 did
they yeah and I'm sure like I know you
earlier you were saying like if you had
to like pick it something with me baby I
would argue with you over drowsy were
more than mission impossible yeah but
like Jurassic world I gladly
acknowledged all the flaws that people
were talking about yeah I didn't justify
the flaws yeah but for some reason it's
it's you because some reason it was a
total [ __ ] blast what a great IMAX
experience great 3d experience on imax
and if it was the experience that I
loved it that's what I walked away from
was not the flaws with the movie I
wasn't like an analytical douchebag but
I was like this movie is just so much
fun well it being analytical isn't bad
but I think I think that's what gives
your list of personality because there
are people who you know do appreciate
more independent or more sophisticated
more complicated films but who also at
the same time you know get down with a
good yeah Buster action movie and i
think that's that's a valid way to do
i've seen more movies than what's in the
top ten one big regret
that I have and I told like I said it
off the top of my head one big regret I
have is not putting Kingsman on the list
yeah I forgot that that was this year
because it came out like in February
cover runners-up well it's not a
runner-up that's like a top ten yeah you
know like kings was pretty right no
Kings that's what I mean Kingsman the
experience of that yeah was so much fun
and I like the characters and it was
different in a lot of ways but paid
homage in a lot of ways it was such a
entertaining fan I love column for a
whole roll that he had yeah you know and
I don't know I thought it was like risky
in a lot of ways and it brought
cognitive movies back to a fun way like
there was an experience it kept the
violence ball so still being fun like
yeah one of the most memorable scenes of
all time for me that church the Church
Massacre because they do the whole Black
Betty song they do the entire song you
know like it's not like they took bits
and pieces of it they I feel like they
choreographed it specifically to that
song yeah you know and it was cool and
it was very memorable very violent in a
very important part of the film yeah
yeah so it wasn't just some like crazy
action sequence you know yeah so
Kingsman i really wish i had
acknowledged that um but real fast I
gotta get the Mission Impossible [ __ ]
off my chest okay mission impossible
when I watched it I was wildly impressed
hey it's the fifth installment yeah and
you know and it's it's hard to keep a
franchise that strong you know on a
fifth installment usually it's like yeah
I got what I wanted from it you know
well yeah how do you keep revisiting the
same characters in the same types of
situations and keep that fresh you know
but rogue nation to me was one of the
best action movies I've ever seen well
duh have you seen it yeah yeah the chase
sequences I thought were fantastic uh
that Tom Cruise's performance I thought
was really cool yeah yeah simon pegg i
thought was awesome the girl rebecca
ferguson she's [ __ ] Chris one of the
coolest like under the charlize theron
and Mad Max fury road
and then you got this girl totally
different and I thought she was super
badass and I hope she returns for the
sequel is none of the woman ever
returned so I would like it and that's
kind of creep like that's kind of shitty
yeah and I will I would really like it
why you return like why are we down to
hell I yeah we gotta have Simon Pegg
ving rhames Tom Cruise or whatever the
girl we can change her like like that's
[ __ ] up like what I find someone cool
and keep her around not only that you
know like the stunts in action all the
obvious stuff of what makes it really
stand out but would really stood out to
me is stuff like that's in the finale
where I'm like whoa this isn't some like
crazy out there violent finale it's more
of like when their toe to toe with
wooden I would like it's a game of wit
you know in that cafe scene with ya but
that's what it becomes with the villain
is a game of wits you know it's it's not
it's like they have Tom Cruise has to
learn how to outsmart this guy he never
can but he has to find a way and it's
like what action movie is willing to do
that these days well yeah cuz it takes
the impossibility from just a crazy
stunt to like oh he's gotta prove his
worth as an agent too well yeah it's got
a not just a badass killer he has to
show like he's got the mindset to handle
like such situations fine in my
recollection of it seems like they do a
decent job at least what you kind of
know that Tom Cruise is gonna be on the
money in the end but throughout the
movie are sort of like what if he's
wrong yeah exactly what if something
about this is in fact wrong yeah exactly
and I loved Alec Baldwin and the twist
at the end I remember would that with
the ending twist that was like that put
a smile on my face I was like that's a
good twist that's a good way to wrap
this movie up you know like it ends the
movie / like the franchise could totally
stop now it could I don't feel like they
need a conclusion film necessarily I
think it could totally end um one thing
I want the franchise to do on a side
note is kind of toy with his age too but
I feel like Tom Cruise looks so [ __ ]
young any way that I did it won't stand
out to you you know he's not awkward
it's not it's not like we're not
treating him like he's aging but it
looks like he's don't looks like
he can pull up the stuffies point
exactly and he does he proves that
because he does his own stunts well yeah
and i think that's that's part of why
that helps you know is because it's like
he's doing it so you can do it they
don't think i don't have to do trick
shots to like cover up the stunt man's
face yeah exactly you you can see it's
Tom Cruise doing it and and that is so
awesome literal manifestation of guys
I'm not too old yeah like so yeah that
movie was entertaining surprising in a
lot of ways felt fresh I felt it was the
best mission impossible and I already
really like the Mission Impossible
movies so yeah that movie stood out to
me the most like it was it had the most
personality and fun and charm that I
felt that the theaters and yeah I felt
that more than Star Wars mmm so yeah an
ex machina though like hot dude that's
film I love that is that is on your top
10 in some way oh hell yeah yeah it's on
both of my top tens that's right I saw
your horror top 10 horror sci-fi movies
yeah do i do one for her inside friend
than i did one for just general films of
the year yeah yeah cuz i feel like you
know I spent enough time sort of
immersed in genre that that you know
that's a whole category I can look at in
and of itself and then you know just
general cinema and I you know like
that's the thing about these lists is
like you think back on a year especially
with as many movies as we see in a year
and you know other I'm sure other
critics and stuff see many more movies
and we've seen here you know it's like
I'm sure many critics know this even
better than we do because you know they
see more movies but it's like when you
look back over a year and you saw
multiple movies in a month you start to
forget like if you just think off the
top your head like what did I see this
here like a lot of stuff becomes
forgettable and the stuff that you
remember is usually the good place to
start because that's the stuff that was
probably you know the most quality to
you for some reason and I always try to
approach a top 10 list that way where
it's like what do I actually remember
what experience stuck with me yeah cuz
nowadays like everything is pitched to
be so exciting and and so you know we're
trying to build these instant classics
but really by the end of the year I'm
like what do I remember
and others are so many and it's not a
ton of them yeah so see ya ex machina
definitely made that was a very
memorable experience from the ass here I
was like yes definitely ex machina like
Oh ex machina was something very special
dude I never released a review for it at
I watched it um like a little bit before
Christmas and I was so like blown away
this is a really cool year for sci-fi
their three sci-fi movies on my list
what are they uh ex machina
predestination and Mad Max fury road I
didn't catch predestination ya know not
a lot of people did they dumped it into
January it's it's hard to describe and
it's hard to advertise that's a guy who
did looper no no no the spirit brothers
who did date breakers oh yeah oh no ryan
Johnson delusion yeah right yeah um the
spirit brothers adapted this Robert
Heinlein short story and it's it's got
to do partially with this I think
they're called the temporal Bureau
basically they're they're trying to stop
crime using time travel essentially but
it's a period piece so it's not quite as
futuristic as everything like oh cool
yeah so it's like time travels invented
in 1985 cool that's kind of where things
start out and he's trying to stop this
bomber but there's a whole other subplot
that comes in with an incredible actress
named Sarah snook uh who's just [ __ ]
great in this movie but it was cool to
have those three movies to me because
they're all kind of sides of a coin is
like I saw ex machina I saw Mad Max and
I was like these are both like
sophisticated sci-fi movies for two
completely different reasons yeah and
it's like there's similar this in the
way that they deal with the human
condition with the gender and stuff like
that at least how they walk around and
sort of comment on those things but you
know on the inverse Mad Max is very look
hi there very few words but it's very
physical and it's a very real idea of a
dystopia and a real sort of theory as to
why it would be that way an ex machina
is very verbose and very intellectual
you know it's kind of the opposite
version of the future but they're both
dealing with these very primal things
and they and they all have surprises and
they blow you they blow you away they're
all 10 C and they're all you know and
you walk away knowing the characters too
yeah totally and so that's why like like
Mad Max was really cool cuz it was a
physical sci fi movie but with a lot
more worth and weight than a lot of the
noisy you know action sci-fi flicks we
get lately and then ex machina was like
a really cool return to science fiction
like really idea driven science fiction
that was also human and then
predestination is very metaphysical and
it deals with paradoxes yeah the more
theoretical aspects of science fiction
and time travel um but in a scientific
way what would you say is your favorite
move your beer is really hard yeah cuz
like especially if you watch something
again you're reminded of like oh like
you know I got to see Mad Max the New
Beverly a couple months ago again it was
just like oh and some and sometimes
you'll like a movie more the second time
you watch it yeah where you'll notice
more things so it's like I've seen I saw
predestination again just the other day
I was like man this is such a great mood
like I really like this movie and it's
strange and it's hard to wrap your mind
around but in a really cool and very
human way like it's yeah it's the kind
of movie where I got ten minutes in and
I was like oh they're still having this
conversation this is a different kind of
movie than I thought the trailer game
I'm but I don't know if favorite movie
of the year i think is still a girl
walks home alone at night i did not
catch that and i saw you put that is
number one on your horror sci-fi list
yeah i mean that's it's a very strange
sort of out there movie it's a like a
vampire western New Wave neo-noir thing
weiser your favorite um it was it was
like the most different sort of
interesting thing like it was at the
center of it all is you know morality
tale and and a sort of twisted little
love story like it's not the most
complicated movie I saw your it is very
stylish but in a in a way that I'm not
used to as much now is very sort of
stylish in a in a atmospheric sort of
subtle way it's all in black and white
no really yeah and it's uh yeah it's
like Iranian
um and Elijah woods company produced it
and I shot like in lancaster but it's
basically supposed to take it place in
this like Iranian slum yeah and the
woman who wrote and directed it is now
doing the bad batch which has like a
bunch of people in it Joe made known Jim
Carrey and merciful it's like a cannibal
web story um oh nice yeah butBut girl
walks home was just like there was so
much mood and it was very sort of creepy
but kind of poignant and beautiful and
strange and it was just it was just so
many things and it was so immersive you
know it really made me feel yeah and it
was all so expressive and you know
original and strange and i don't know i
just i was so enamored you know i'm
getting a lot of crap on for my list too
what's an inside out why what is that
that was surprising to me why um that
insect I don't know people were just
like it's overrated you know and stuff
and I I watched it and I thought it was
[ __ ] brilliant yeah it's so
imaginative yeah and very just it's so
creative in the sense of like exploring
the mentality and giving a character and
like that was it was trippy it was a
trippy movie and the first time I
watched it I was like I'm having a hard
time like really being invested at times
cuz it's kind of causing me anxiety
because it's like it's theirs it really
deals with the mind yeah and it does it
in a way where kids can understand it
and kids can learn from it like an
adults can learn from it you know like
it teaches a sophisticated message
nowadays it's like I had an argument
about this nut uronian but like a
discussion about this between the good
dinosaur and between inside out this
year and it's like I think the good
dinosaur make something good out of a
story we've seen a million times but
this like inside out basically takes a
lesson that I'm not used to seeing it's
like I liked it for a similar reason I
liked paranorman is because like the
message at the heart of these movies is
not just be yourself or you know believe
or life is not like light life is light
and dark
and you should embrace your emotions
well yeah it's like this movie is
basically going like no no no it's
important to be sad sometimes it's
important to feel things that aren't
just happy yeah so you can be a
well-rounded person and so that you know
it's like you wouldn't be happy without
sadness you wouldn't be and it shows
that anger can block you off to yeah and
and joy can block you out angel yeah
exactly cuz it's part of like the whole
point it is like you know joy keeps me
going no no I got this we're gonna do
this like Joy's in denial yes such as
like people do that they it's like
people will especially nowadays do
people are so like I will watch like the
secret which is wonderful however if
you're living in la-la land where it's
all positive all positive and a time
something negative happens it's like
nope just gotta think positively it's
it's [ __ ] you know like and I feel
this movie's great at acknowledging
certain things that I feel we need to be
more aware of and it's great that they
did it in a way where kids can
understand it cuz its most important for
kids to understand that yeah it's like
nothing's wrong with you if you're sad
you should be sad sometimes sadness is a
is a valid and useful emotion yeah and
you know three quarters way through
that's kind of the point for joy's is to
go like hey you don't got this right now
you don't have to just shower happiness
on everything because that's not gonna
make things better in the long run yeah
and that's that's very now because
nowadays it's like we have this sort of
aggressive inspiration porn what it's
like never question yourself you're
[ __ ] awesome don't crush it and I'm
like sometimes you have to like question
yourself and allow yourself to be sad
life should be grey it shouldn't be you
know just black and white well I should
be a spectrum of colors it should be a
changing spectrum of colors that's a
much better way to put it yeah you know
that's why they're okay I know they're
all color-coded yeah you know that's why
memories are you know it's like you
experience the range and that's how you
become a functioning you know healthy
human being you know ya round it you see
this is what I mean now i'm talking
about it I wish I put it in like my top
five yeah you see I had it his number
eight at the time when I made the video
yeah but now it's like it's my tall 500
k night like this movie made me cry a
lot like it is like yeah I [ __ ] bald
at the end
I don't blame me I mean it takes a very
sort of emotionally resonant idea and
adds some pretty heavy stakes perhaps
the heaviest stakes of all it's like
this is all taking place in somebody's
mind like this is the foundations of a
human beings existence yeah yeah I
thought they portrayed that very well
without like going like she was the girl
closely in the movie was like making
decisions where I was like that's kind
of brave in some ways for them to make
them make the kid sort of go down that
route again in half and then have it
come back have been the ending
conclusion of the governor Carter well
cuz I computer like like everything it's
like you can you can relate to like a
child being truly lost yeah you know
wanting to do what she did what it's
enough it's a crib to the animators
because when they actually reached
depression for her yeah that look on her
face is like oh [ __ ] like I've like it
made me think like oh like that is the
fit like you know cuz it's not even sad
anymore it's just kind of empty like
didn't they they went places like that
which I yes exactly um what else is on
your list um my list I saw another
animated movies here I guess we're
Chinese very much out of work yeah no
this isn't this isn't in some [ __ ]
specific order like that's yes that's
the whole point of this podcast is that
you really can't do that well cuz they
have an idea of what your order would be
there is like I've never been very good
at ordering a top tank so the movies
were different I try to just whip it out
that way I'd hot whip it up I try just
like you know quickly do it that way I'm
not like overthinking sometimes okay
let's see what's next so we've talked
about a girl walks on the loan at night
we've talked about ex machina we talked
about Mad Max predestination hello
sci-fi yeah um and inside out um
anomalisa was another oh you caught that
yeah dude i ah man so jealous yeah I
haven't been able to watch it yet um
it's it's a it's playing around town
dude I really want to watch that movie
Charlie Kaufman is first off one of my
all-time favorite writers so I know that
he did that will a cynic doke was it Oh
synecdoche new year
well got that word wrong yeah I know he
did that but it didn't get like the best
feedback and I didn't personally enjoy
it too much and that was his like
directorial debut and then I heard he
directed this one too which is [ __ ]
amazing and it's getting incredible
reviews the trailer blew me away well
this one this one is co-directed and I
like it he co-directed it with a guy who
I think works for star burns who is Sir
burns industries does a lot of the
stop-motion animation stuff on adult
swim and there's nothing wrong with co
directing it to like this we take away
credit from it because matter all I'm
saying like it's kind of cool because
you get the sense that Charlie Charlie
Kaufman is a very you know his movies
are very sort of emotional and kind of
melancholy in a very specific way in a
very sort of life II way yeah but like
with a touch of Sir reality so it's like
he can really sculpt these little
emotional performances and he's also got
a co-director whose whole thing is
stop-motion who's hold me to ask visuals
so you put those together and it makes a
great yeah aw dude I'm so jealous I
really want to watch that movie what I
mean I didn't really know much about it
going in um I didn't really know exactly
what it was about other than like I knew
it involved you know stop motion and
kind of sad discourses on love hmm but
it's it's a lot more things than that
it's very raw it's very raw movie to
watch you know is because it's it's it
makes use of the fact that it's animated
pretty well where it's like they mostly
look human you look pretty close to
human but you can see like the seams
where the bottom half of their face on
the top half their face would go nice so
it calls attention to the fact that this
is stop motion it's not like trying to
it's like if you watch fantastic mr fox
everything is kind of not trying to let
you know that but there are moments in
this movie where things get surreal and
actually like the pieces start to come
off and things that are very drunk
uh but yeah that's crazy uh I wanna
watch it yeah it's it's that we're kind
of you know Charlie Kaufman sorted
really good at making this movie that
starts out being just a series of
mundane situations just like oh he's on
this business trip and he's talking to
the cabbie and the cabbie is kind of
silly and then he gets to the hotel and
he has to deal with the concierge and
it's just all these tiny little moments
but that are somehow made so human
because they're translated in a literal
yeah way in the visuals and their
choices of sounds because like there are
only three voice actors in the whole
movie which is David Thewlis is the main
character michael Stone and then
Jennifer Jason Leigh oh cool is Lisa and
then everybody else is voiced by Tom
Noonan so everyone has the same voice
okay in this guy's world cuz that's how
sort of just detached from everything
he's because it's [ __ ] brilliant like
mike coffman blows me away with his
stories yeah man this movie was like a
pile just like I felt like it knocked me
over a little bit I think it's Eternals
sunshine is one of my all-time favorite
films yeah yeah I want to watch that one
again but then I watch like adaptation
I'm like wait nevermind adaptation and I
watch being john malkovich I'm like wait
no being John member cuz he's he's so
great at doing these like slightly
surreal or heightened situations but
putting this like and very raw very
human element onto yeah it's crazy you
know and it's like it's just not the
kind like he finds the beauty and the
struggle in these mundane situations
that you would never even see in most
movies yeah like you wouldn't just see
this guy's day it's this weird sort of
oxymoronic thing where it's both mundane
and profound yeah yeah so it's like yeah
you I felt the [ __ ] up um what else do
you got almost but creep I didn't see
co-creator creep creep creep is a
runner-up for me just because like
jumping over from lit I debated about
having it on my top 10 list cuz i really
liked it like I really liked I didn't
know much about it other than you know
the Blumhouse movie and Mark Duplass was
involved and I watched it and that was
just such a fun surprise because it's
totally different than your average
found footage and it is playing with
your
rotations of found footage I like movies
I do that yeah so it's like you know
Mark Duplass does this very sort of
naturalistic improv style with a lot of
his movies and you get that sense it's
like you're just kind of watching two
guys over the course of the situation
but the things that it finds creepy
within that are altogether more creative
and the way it treats like the horror
movie stuff is kind of silly so like
it's it's a really different kind of
found footage movie which is also why
some people didn't like it they're like
oh this is scary you know but if you
want to see something that's like that
tweaks it in a cool way and a thoughtful
way and you know I don't know I like I'm
that kind of like that kind of like
makes me because one of my runner-ups is
the visit okay see different sides of a
coin yeah yeah and the visit was one of
those movies that totally wasn't it mess
with my expectations in such a
delightful way yeah it's like I thought
it was so fun it was fun scary you know
it wasn't like trying to be this serious
scary movie I liked how it was like a
[ __ ] there were fun scares you know and
it like you be laughing but be scared at
the same time I mean yeah yeah it's
having fun with you and it's
acknowledging certain things and I think
that's what both of those movies do want
in entirely different ways they both
bring in humor but not where you're
expecting it to be yeah that's cool
that's really cool so yeah just creep
does it in a different way for me and
creep was also like I debated on you
think of types of movies that might fit
the slots of your top ten and creep was
the one round like this is really subtle
and kind of loaf I so it's not super
flashy yeah in the in the way that it's
good and I like it but I kind of want to
include it because it's not super flashy
like you know so it's a close runner-up
on this little late on your list yes it
is yes yes wait right now hateful eight
is like number nine oh really yeah i did
it again i like these these these will
change these ratings always change like
I never know how I feel like with a
second viewing i would probably rate
hateful eight even higher maybe it plays
very differently the second time you saw
two ice yeah i texted you about it um
you did yeah cuz the second time I was
watching I'm like I don't think he did
this like like there's just their
moments like that you like you
pick up uh ha row that's why you were
talking to me about it ok yeah you pick
up harder on the mannerisms and certain
things people were saying and so you
think to yourself ok so knowing what I
know about these people that's probably
a lie but this could be true actually
and that thing I thought was true before
i think is now a lie Oh Dan there are
questions I want to ask you then you
know so it's yeah there were things
maybe maybe go back a couple of minutes
and cut out that one detail well that's
the thing with the hateful eight that
that movie gives you an experience
especially in the theaters you know that
it's like yes some people might be like
well if you didn't go to the special
orkla thing it might not be as good then
I'm like it might not it doesn't matter
that's like the way Tarantino really
wants you to watch it one and I don't
know how they'll do the release of this
on home video or whatever but yeah
things that made it special to be there
for why will still be on that DVD yeah
it's not like oh there was a cool thing
in the lobby and then we saw it and it
was magical they gave us free popcorn
it's like the overture and the
intermission are still there if they
release that cut you know it's like you
can get the visual appreciation off of
that from something older something
people used to we don't do anymore you
know they're intermission of hateful
eight the intermission of hateful eight
had a more powerful ending scene had a
more powerful scene yeah like prior to
the intermission then a lot of movies at
end would like that are part 1 and part
2 yeah you know like when they split a
movie in half yeah it like when it cut
to intermission people were like so
hooked and then it cuts intermission at
the perfect time I'd like this perfect
time to get the whole audience talking I
wonder if kill bill kind of made this
possible and in certain ways because
it's of all of his movies it's very much
not like the kill bills of his career
but like I wonder it lightly if you've
seen the whole bloody affair cut of kill
bill like the place you know they recut
certain things so it's not meant to be
one and two it's one whole movie yeah
and I think there was an intermission I
think it's that same sort of thing where
they cut on just the right moment to
have to be like a crescendo that gets
really excited and then you really want
to see what's next after this
after the intermission like this styles
change a little bit because the story
progresses somewhere else yeah exactly
you know it's like there I wonder if he
had that in mind going into the hateful
eight because like it works really well
in the hatefully like it's I was like
when that intermission came and then the
way it comes back with a bit of more of
like a groovy like okay now the movie
knows that something's going down to
like you know I thought it was it was
cut in half incredibly well though yeah
and I could see why he thought he could
adapt it into a novel I was like these
are our two halves yeah of the same
story but there are two different halves
Oh totally communally really well [ __ ]
goes down yeah it does 1 and L so it
kind of fills my spot for things that
are like you know it's kind of art made
out of ugliness you know Oh totally
because it's like all these characters
are sort of ambiguous morally and there
are multiple characters who embody both
things that you really detest in people
and things that you really Myron people
bed so I can become this weird you know
ugly character study there's also got a
lot of rhythm and pulp um I'm I'm
curious to know what your other ones are
okay okay okay now let's see a bone
tomahawk i put on my legs did not catch
either don't talk to Russell may be
right yeah yeah he said I think they
must have filmed pretty close together
because he's got like the same mustache
burns oh really yeah not as uh not as
like scuzzy as you play John Wayne again
no he's a little more subdued he's not
like big okay I mean Kurt Russell like
you can kind of argue that he is a kind
of a John Wayne type in certain ways
anyway but like in in bone tomahawk it's
very straight performance like it's a
very earnest performance um and bone
tomahawk I don't know there are a lot of
like weird pairs on my list is Yuri a
bone tomahawk was really cool because it
is just a straight it's a Western that
happens to be also a horror movie I
heard it's like a like it honors the
western theme in a way where it's like a
Western Western you know
yeah it's very straight like it's I I
regarded as being a horror movie in the
sense that leg the way any horror movie
takes place on a normal day that's about
to become not normal you know like this
has that it's just like on a normal day
in the 1800s you know just because of
where it's set you know it's still a
normal day in that society and then
something strange happens hmm and so it
does feel hurry to me but but yeah it's
also just a straight Western because
it's like they have to go they basically
are on a search party to find Patrick
Wilson's wife and it feels like deal but
like it takes its time they don't brush
past that journey the journey is as
perilous as the rest of the movie and
the people together are as perilous to
each other in certain ways as the rest
of the movie so like it's very Western
in that sense it's like you're traveling
with a with a band of you know people on
a mission you know there's gray justice
and you know and it explores the side of
that that world you know dude I [ __ ]
love westerns I do too wonders are this
it's like only a west yeah like westerns
have such a specific type of vibe and
movie and like a the mood it creates
everything about a Western is just puts
you in a different world yeah it's like
close enough to reality yeah but some
stuff is probably you know pretty
fictitious like I I don't know actually
you know yeah well that's the thing is
like you look at bone tamaki look at
hateful eight like hateful eight is kind
of like the thing meets reservoir dogs
I've heard some people yeah and it is
like there there are certain elements it
are horrific like that and whereas bone
tamaak is kind of like it is a western
meets something else you know yeah yeah
like just the styles are different there
and it's it's really well done it's
really well written it's very like
sparse in the way it's captured but
great like it's it does that Western
thing where it really takes advantage of
its locations so they'll have these
giant sprawling shots of them traveling
somewhere you know just to to establish
the scenery and the cast is really good
too like Kurt Russell's great Patrick
Wilson is really good Matthew Fox from
lost
fantastic is he yeah he is he's really
good and and Richard Jenkins no way
Richard Jenkins in that yeah and he's
almost unrecognizable like he's so good
like I love Richard Jenkins yeah Richard
Jenkins one of the main characters and
he's so good they're also a couple
cameos that that are at the beginning
that are unexpected in a kind of cool
way yeah but yeah just the way it does
it and then the kind of movie is like it
was really cool experience like it takes
its time this or flashing movie but it's
it's really well done that's cool the
curve rustles like in to Westerners at
the same time yeah and I mean the guy
who did bone tomahawk I mean he's done
some cinematography and stuff but he's
mainly I think a novelist oh really yeah
he's written a lot of novels and this is
his first writing and directing gig as a
filmmaker so it's you know you kind of
have fun in Terrence you know in a
different side as per dollar and turning
around different sides because it's like
this guy I think wanted to make movies
and got into books and now he's finally
making his move in and you know you
might have Tarantino in the opposite
side of that oh yeah I go you're saying
yeah you know OOP kitty kitty hey bud um
I'm dying to know what your number one
is we've already talked about my number
one oh yeah we did yeah these are all
out of order we jumped in because he is
a mission puzzled everything we just
kind of jumped in and yeah sort of
discussed our favorite movies out of
order did you um I mean did you do ten
movies ready okay I guess we can wreak
it I guess we'll just in a weird way is
like I'll recap those we've talked about
yeah at least for my list cuz people
know your eyes um okay so a girl walks
on it this is the order as I have it
right now it's like a girl walks I'm
alone is my number one number two I put
his ex machina this time number three
mad max number four predestination all
that kind of hesitate to lump three
Syfy's together if you like they should
be interspersed so I might rewrite this
with and then 6 is 0 or 5 is the one I
hadn't got it
but yeah which is what what we do in the
shadows oh is that the guy from flight
of the conchords yeah which I might come
up to number four I don't know like the
Empire film yeah like it's hard
comparing all these moves but what we do
the shadows was such a such a fun treat
like like I when I worked when when Jim
Crow was still open i worked there my
boss is from New Zealand and he got a
copy of the movie and we screened it
before I played here and you know it was
just so much fun cuz I knew very little
except like jemaine clement taika
waititi were involved and I saw it and I
was like I almost couldn't stand behind
the counter if it was cracking up so
much that's cool like it's it's just
about four vampires living in Wellington
and they're all like kind of over a
hundred years old but it's kind of
taking that as though it were just a
real situation so it's like these guys
are roommates they do argue over who
does the dishes and stuff but they also
go out at nights and like try and prey
on people in clubs and stuff and they're
like organizations for them like it's
like what the most realistic version but
with some vampire fantasy thrown in yeah
then we was a blast yeah and it's like
it's fun cuz like it's it's all so tight
cuz you know it's very improv heavy
comedy but they never beat a joke into
the ground nothing else stays its
welcome it's only like 85 or 90 minutes
oh cool so it's like it's nice to
finally see a is on netflix maybe now or
who or who lure grams I really did want
to watch that too it's so much fun like
it's the thing is like it it's an improv
heavy comedy that actually had an editor
yeah so like it moves nicely like it's
it was just such a treat like it's so
much fun in there like so many great
quotes and there's so many fun
characters and clever little things and
it's totally quirky and weird but it's
it's it's just so much fun you know yeah
so much fun so creative so yeah and then
animal least a inside-out bone tom mckay
filleted and the last one on my list was
end of the tour what's that one that's
one with jesse eisenberg and jason segel
or hippo yeah Foster Wallace yeah murder
that like that was a movie just about
two dudes talking the whole time in
different places and under different you
know sort of circumstances on this book
tour but most the actions to
talking it's great like it was so it was
entertaining but it was also engrossing
and it was also you know kind of
poignant was it funny yeah very funny
like that's on netflix like it's not
comedy per se but like the nature of who
you know these guys are there's a lot of
quips and a lot of humor you know Jason
Segel was quite interesting to me mm-hmm
cuz I think he's grown as an actor yeah
but on how i met your mother it always
seemed aware that he was on a sitcom
yeah because he because he goes for more
of like like I love him and I love you
man he goes for more like the dry kind
of humor in movies but then he was on
the sick or he was really in a sick up
so it's kind of strange to me how is how
is acting and that was much more
heightened and stuff I almost had wished
that like he'd played Marshall Eriksen
as [ __ ] what's his name on Freaks and
Geeks yeah like if he'd played a little
more like that character just grown up
that might have maybe he would have been
a little more natural yeah cuz it
especially after watching him be natural
or natural and movies and then going I
want to check out how i met your mother
was like interesting well but he's
playing on he's playing a different kind
of role they're like but what we doing
but not not what we do in the shadows um
what's it called oh I ended the end of
the tour I I think that's on netflix i
got to check that out too yeah yeah i
really liked it Matt like and I didn't
know a lot of a David Foster Wallace are
about infinite jest which is the book he
wrote and you know much about the
circumstances of his life further than
he you know committed suicide and stuff
but um you know it was such an
interesting movie to see and it was also
very enjoyable had a lot of rhythm it
was nicely shot like do you see Jason
Segel's penis no don't think so I can
google it yeah I want you to yeah I
would like to see it yet I can check you
won't forget that Marshall no you won't
yeah i like how much
I wonder he's willing to do that for
call me as if you did no [ __ ] penis
[ __ ] Jason Segel anyway guys yeah
that's our podcast for today discussing
some of our favorite movies of 2015 oh
did you have any runners-up ring finger
runners-up um no I just really wanted to
mention Kingsman okay um do you have
runners up maybe a couple I mean like
these are things that at least one
dimensions like I really liked Krampus a
lot oh yeah another one a lot of people
described as being like kind of like
poltergeist meets gremlins it was nice
to have that kind of movie again and to
be sort of so much fun and also kind of
dark and the way the trick or treat is
like yeah I got that they did a real
good job with crazy you know ant-man
actually surprised me okay you know a
lot of people like wars adventures and
I'm like I didn't even consider putting
that it's not that I hate the movie yeah
I think it's a really fun movie like
it's a total blast but I didn't ever
have a desire to go back to the theaters
and watch it again yeah you know
Avengers but when it came to ant-man
that movie like genuinely surprised me
marble felt fresh it was really it was
its funniest movie i've ever seen from
marble you know comedy was like one of
the genres of the film and yeah so I am
man to me was a strong strong
consideration when I was trying to
compile a list together okay goosebumps
was it was like a fun runner up for me
just because like you know it's goose
bumps but they did it kind of the
perfect way and like I don't really get
a like bent out of shape about like oh
my childhood but like you know goose
bumps I was a big fan oh so I was sort
of liking I hope they do this right and
I was just so that was the one where I
just had so much fun that I felt like a
kid again like I thought they handled
that perfectly oh I really like right
along well you're in luck is right or
wrong a lot of ride along 2 is good
right around the corner yeah get on the
board that ride-along 30 50 shades of
grey was great mmm
yeah and everyone's on board for chappie
everyone pretty much hey I like shafi a
lot like chappie too I don't think I'd
put a put on my top 10 but I did like
chappie a lot more than most people did
yeah me too like maybe like I get the
sense like not the sense i get that
maybe mel uh maybe uh [ __ ] was named
Hugh Jackman's performance is a little
too big no Mel Gibson yeah Mel Gibson a
huge a bizarre honest is maybe a little
too big for that movie but but as a
whole i really like that oh and i think
um i think paul blart mall cop 2 yeah
shout out to david henrie should be on
there too that that would be good
there's a horror movie I watched it is
on netflix he'll let us pray that was
wicked really yeah it's like a it's like
an Irish for me Oh san andreas I was
like everyone's favorite number one of
the list I believe every critic with
that movie on there mathematically
perfect the entourage way we didn't
disappoint critics hey I know you're
looking forward and Ted to was a really
strong follow-up sequel that provided
something super fresh so strong i almost
bought you like a ted bobble and
terminator genisys as james cameron says
it is the truce terminator 3 in a lot of
ways oh no it wasn't i had a lot of fun
but hey dude trust me i'm quoting people
and fantastic for you know that it had
it struggles on set wasn't perfect but
overall i said why i see why critics and
audience you just really like the movie
ya know hold a boat took it like without
fantastic for performing so well Creed
wouldn't have performs so ugly people
like oh we gotta check this with ya dude
oh and i love the reboot of the
transporter oh man why that gotta love
Game of Thrones too high yeah dude and
that awesome thriller that's like a
fatal attraction with a black people the
perfect guy hey we like the perfect yeah
that's true we like their trailer anyway
and decay and pan wasn't disappointing
not at all those kinds of move
never and I thought paranormal activity
the dimension ended on a perfect note
you didn't even see paranoid because I
sure did and if you watch my review for
Spectre you'll see I clearly loved the
movie yeah and so nobody argued with you
or that ya know totes oh you know what I
should have put on what the night before
I wish I did enjoy them I was genuinely
surprised by that like I wasn't
expecting to laugh at all and then I was
there were parts where i was really
cracking up i was expecting it to be
okay and it was ok to me but but there
were certain things that stood out as
being like may I really like that like
you know little emotional moment or I
really like that right like recurring
joke so like yeah the movie is kind of a
mess to me like like in terms of like
the way the story moves but those
characters is so much fun to watch and
like Michael Shannon is [ __ ]
incredible and everything oh and how
could I forget it's weird but in a kind
of cool way like it's it throws in these
ideas it wouldn't normally this movie
this year ended on a really strong note
with the remake of point break oh yeah
totally loved it I loved how they
modernized the film that was not too
long ago I like how they remade a film
that you know kind of relies on Keanu
Reeves Patrick Swayze and gary is he in
specific and then remade it without
those people and it's crazy how get
Patrick Swayze it's crazy that you know
they didn't just cast Keanu Reeves in it
because evidently he still looks like he
can just be a continuation of the same
character because he doesn't look bad
for his age at all I just want to like
who looked at Point Break and was like
people want to see this story over again
it's like people love that movie because
of the people in that yeah you like the
story's been done to death it's not the
same without Keanu Reeves like Patrick
Swayze Gary Busey lori petty and and
flee like like it sir anthony kiedis
whoever's never like it's those people
and that time that make that movie is
what make people love it it's the swayze
reeves romance that's why people love
point yeah dude I can
you agree with you anyway we got to wrap
this video up guys cameras dying too
much all right I'm sure we'll think of
more subscribe to the real rejects right
reasons to GRE movie reviews guest up
another podcast I have trailer reaction
reviews youtube video reaction
discussions I have what sounds like a
ball